Leave the World Behind everyone's
roasting Julie Roberts about her dancing
in it
dude I I don't here's the deal okay I
was watching Le Leave the World Behind
first of all I don't like the movie okay
I said
it the acting is phenomenal I said it
don't like the movie and I'm not even a
guy who doesn't like a movie because of
how the ending is but dude saw the movie
the ending was it just it I didn't like
the movie everyone's talking about this
movie it's number one on Netflix number
two on Netflix Julia Julia
Roberts there she is so awesome at
acting she is the creme de La Creme of
actors okay there is a movie there's a
scene where she dances with a guy
marshala mahara what is it Mah Mersa Ali
I mean that's you know there's an extra
Allah in there that I don't you know her
la
la la la la la la
la and dude she's dancing and she is so
weirdly dancing and everyone's roasting
her online for it you put the video here
but let me tell you something about
this I didn't know that people were
roasting her and I saw the movie right
when it came out so they probably
weren't roasting her yet so I saw this
movie okay we can't so first of all
she's dancing to that [__] me you're
drining you get so excited oh how I like
it I try but I can't find it oh you're
dancing real slow but I get you real low
you're making it hard for me wow I guess
I know that whole song I had no idea wow
baby wait go you excited oh Bing real
slow I get the real and making it hard
for me
like sex oh
yeah yeah whatever anyway um that song
by next is it why do I know it I why do
I know this
dude I don't know but that song gave me
eargasms when I was younger I never
liked that song honestly but anyway it's
dope that they put that in this movie in
the in an end of the world movie you
know what I'm saying like they like the
producer the director was like yo I know
the perfect
song oh we're dancing real
slow and you're making it hard for me
that means penis by the way um he does
not talk about difficult I mean he is
talking about difficult but it's an
innuendo and he's talking about hard
he's talking about his penis you you
know is that the one that feels a little
poke coming through on
you so fraking to the point so
um uh anyway I'm watching this movie and
and now Julia Roberts is dancing now
look if you think of um Great White
actress dancing you probably think bad
you know just like has so much money
what is her life like she doesn't dance
you know like you know how like
Gangsters Don't Dance they Boogie how M
10 said that and then it's like well
dude nobody doesn't dance more than a
gangster okay but then it's like a
really really really really rich white
woman and I don't mean a housewife when
the when the when the husband leaves and
she's got the kitchen to herself in her
two-bedroom house I'm talking about
someone with houses that has people do
[__] for them day and night they don't
dance dude they they get people to dance
for them they're kings and queens
they're just you know they'll put on
necks and they'll be like I feel like
dancing I need someone to fulfill that
dance for
me and then someone comes out oh they're
dancing real slow you're making it hard
for me and they don't move [__] so Julia
Roberts is an actress though and this
scene calls upon her to dance so we get
to see either how this character Julia
Roberts is playing is dancing and how
she decides this character is dancing or
how the real Julia Robert dances we
don't know we don't know so roasting her
is pretty much silly because it's the
character
okay and there's this thing on Tik Tok
where it's like and the acting award
goes to Maha La laa for keeping a
straight face while watching Julie
Roberts trying to dance now we don't
like that kind of roasting here on
congratulations because this is the
character dude if I'm in a movie and it
calls for me to dance unless I play a
dancer I'm doing it silly okay why
because it adds to the movie you see me
dancing on TV I'm having a a silly
time now if I'm in Magic mic and I got
to do B
p
p p and I got to be real sexy I got to
take dance classes okay I got to
actually try but this here she's dancing
a a little poke coming through on you so
she's doing it like the character either
way I was watching this movie and I was
in by the way the first half of this
movie and the dancing happens in the
first for the
movie or like maybe into the it's into
the movie now
m m la la la la la of course is good at
dancing he's better at dancing than he
is at smiling when Mahala La D Smiles he
knows that that gets the penties wet and
I just go it gets the panties wet it
kind of It kind of even gets my panties
wet and I'm not not in a gay way I'm
just like I'll give it to him I'll piss
a little
bit uh you know what I'll let it out a
little bit you know when a guy's really
good-looking as a man if you're really
comfortable with your heterosexuality
you got to get wet too and piss a little
bit just give it to him you know what
I'm talking
about
right
so Julia Roberts starts dancing and dude
I'm first of all I'm in the I'm in it
I'm in the movie okay fine that's cool
Julia Roberts starts dancing and she
dances is very
weird actually no even worse than that
she dances kind of weird
and it's very subtle and kind of
weird and I'm going to just go ahead and
say she did it as a character cuz she is
just top- notot jaing but when I saw her
dancing in that here I'll play it a
little bit I'm not going to do the music
because we'll get demonetized
but God she's a great actress dude I
mean she's dancing like she's you know
in like West Side Story the blind
version but she's just got no and and
and next to a black guy who's Obviously
good at dancing because he's black but
man he she is just like God she's so
good dude when I saw this scene I was
like Julia Roberts I actually texted the
group chat when I saw this dancing I
texted my my friends I go man Julia
Roberts is on another level of acting
and she really is dude I love Julie
Roberts and I always have
and she is doing it like a lane from
Seinfeld's a little bit but you know
it's okay but that movie boy I I didn't
I'm not wasn't in it you know but she
was also like playing you know a kind of
like a Karen role so that's how they
dance uh she killed it dude hats off to
Julie Roberts I think she should win an
Oscar just for that dancing